وليد موضوعنا قبل شوي كان على توظيف
الذكاء الاصطناعي ومستقبل السوشيال ميديا
مع اذا كان اسمها في 20 22 انا قبل ما
ادخل على حسابك على انستغرام هيك تخيلت
وسالت نفسي انه معقول يكون وليد من الناس
الي نزله صورهم باستخدام الاي اييه وكيف
يرى ذكر السناعي فعلا اول ما فتحت لقيت
صورك شايفك اذا كان الفضاء
الصناعي في السوشيال ميديا مستقبلا في
الدنيا كلها
وراح يكون عندك قرين رقمي حلو
ههه
طيب مصطفى انت عندك مليون ونص مليون
متابعه على مواقع التواصل الله يزيدهم
العام القادم شو الطريقه الخاصه اللي
خليتك تستقطب كل هذا الجمهور على مواقع
التواصل هذا الاهتمام والنجاح والله مش
عايز اكبر المواضيع بس هو احترام احترام
عقل اللي بيتفرج ان احنا نحاول نقدم له
حاجه تحترم عقله ويحس بها ان هي يعني
تلمسه في شكل في اخر من حياته يعني